all right Dior yes Dior where'd you grow
up where are you from I grew up in
Moreno Valley
which is where Riverside County
and tell me about your family
I came from a nice home
um I think oh my dad ended up going to
jail so
everything fell apart but I grew up in a
nice home good Mom good dad I got
brothers and sisters
um
yeah
how do you describe your childhood in
general my childhood it was good
I didn't have a bad childhood at all
how'd you end up on the streets
um through another female
yeah
hanging out with other females I ended
up like in this uh situation in this uh
predicament
predicament yeah yeah it is a
predicament right
you've been doing it since how long I've
been doing this since I was about 15.
but when I first started I was like um
on and off with it like I
when she introduced me to it it was like
POF back then you know plenty of fish so
I really wasn't outside walking blades
and stuff
and then I stopped Towing
I moved to Vegas once I came back to out
here to well to Moreno Valley did you
finish High School no
I was in jail and I didn't even finish
in there
but no I didn't
but um
yeah once uh
actually once I came back out here
that's when I started hitting uh my
first blade was Imperial Highway
and then I start hitting Figaroa
that's where torture came right
you've heard your fence yeah
tell me about working for a Pimp
working for a Pimp hmm
working for a Pimp is like stressful
because
pimps it comes with a lot of hoes right
and a lot of holes come with a lot of
different problems emotions you know
and it's just like
I don't know I don't think I was fit for
it like to pay a pimp like I I'm pretty
sure they paid about one pimp a month or
maybe two pimps in my whole life because
I'm not fit for that type of I don't
have time to do it a [ __ ] with a whole
bunch of females that
you got too many problems it don't even
make enough money for all these problems
and then it you know and then you start
feeling some type of way so it's like
pimps is just and they they like to to
like pimps like I don't know how to
explain it they're just too like
all off of bits all off a female all of
a female
how does it feel to be supporting
him and and his lifestyle only thing he
is your hard work I'm supporting him but
is he supporting me 100
no so it's like you start looking at it
different you know like okay if I would
have took my own money I could probably
be in this situation right here you feel
me I could have been probably did this
with my own money
and then they were like what is he doing
my money I'm stealing what a hotel room
getting outfits every day and been with
this [ __ ] over 30 days I don't got no
car yet I don't got no apartment still
doing the same thing so it'll be like
that's like a headache to me I I don't
um
I wouldn't want to oh yeah you
free to leave if you want
well with pants well with pimps as in
are you free to leave as in with them in
your sight go go Renegade
if they see you it's going to be a
problem you feel me it's going to be a
problem and if they know you Renegade it
might beat your ass they might take
everything you got you know because you
don't got nobody Who you gonna call you
even me you can't call nobody so yeah
on that end yeah you yeah you were um
not wanna run from a gorilla pimp at all
you wouldn't want to be nowhere where he
can catch you
drugs
uh I smoke weed
what else have I done
uh pop perks before
and [ __ ] that's about it yeah
um yeah that's about it what hours do
you typically work
sure I'm a 24-hour hoe like I whole
every day seven days a week seven days a
week every day all day it never stops
like how much do you make a day
um as of now
as of now if I work
if I work from
probably like five in the morning to
about
for money chef sometimes I might split
it up I might make six
and then I might make another six that's
twelve hundred it depends on what type
of date it is because you know every day
has its days so usually on figure I can
make about 15 to 2 000 but on a slow day
probably just a thousand dollars
but um back then that's still good money
yeah but back then when I was younger I
used to make more money than that like
way more money but what do you know I'm
19. so when you were younger meaning 15
16 17 yeah even more yes I was like figs
like going for me I used to love it
there like I used to want to stay all
day all night you know I used to love
fig like go back in my room take a
shower get just go back right back
outside like it used to be good it's
horrifying to imagine a 15 year old girl
16 year old girl out on fig making
two thousand dollars a night you're
right sleeping with how many guys that's
that's 10 20 30. I mean not necessarily
because I used to play the internet too
so I text I'm young you feel me I'm
texting so
you can make money if I get two dates
for 250 that's already
um 500 right I get another date for
another 250. that's a thousand so that's
only four days in total do that again
you're only catching like
eight dates to make
um probably almost two thousand dollars
yeah
but and then on top of it are you
playing the internet and the blade so
it's like you going to out calls and
calls and you're getting the blame money
so it's like
you're not I'm not really catching it
seems like I'm catching that many days
but I'm not because I text to go to my
room it isn't no you know I tax 150 to
go to my room you know so it's like
it adds up and you know they like to tip
you and give you extra money so it don't
be like 10 or 20 days it actually don't
it'd be like a few no more probably than
ten yeah because you can hustle them and
get a little more money out of them I
mean yeah all you got to do literally
when it comes to tricks all you have to
do is be nice like literally just be
sweet don't be that [ __ ] for the
attitude and too cocky and rushing them
you for me because at the end of the day
a trick when it comes to a trick you
can't rational trick to nut or do none
of that because if you're rushing him
he's not going tonight and then he's
gonna feel like you're rushing him right
he's gonna you know so at the end of the
day as long as you don't do that and you
sweet to them
you know there bless you on me they like
Mommy I like you give me your number you
go some extra money or you know so be
like it'd be cool tell me about the guys
that pick you up
um a lot of guys that pick me up are
like my Rangers no cat right how long
I've been on fig most of the guys I
didn't already dated like they know me I
know them so
any like most of the guys I see on fig
they they pay me they pay me probably
200 and up when they come and see me
and some of my regular records I've been
doing since I was a minor but they
didn't know I was a minor they paid me
like four
but they feel bad when I used to when I
told them like I was young back then
when we was having sex they was like you
know their mind's blown but it's like
they didn't know you were no underage
no but maybe they can tell but they only
could believe what I'm telling them
right so yeah you would tell the guys
that you're 18. definitely why would I
not but you were 15 16. yeah 17. a
little girl
and then I end up having a baby
I was in jail my whole pregnancy who's
the father
the father
um he's working right now his name is
Anthony
he's out working right now
um
but I was in jail my whole pregnancy and
got out the day I had my baby and ended
up going right back to jail for um
for human trafficking
you got charged with human trafficking
no no no no no not human trafficking me
I went back to jail for prostitution
because I was still a minor when I had
my baby
where's your child now my baby is over
in Corona
he was raising my mom
do you want to be with your child or you
want to be here no I'll be I'll be with
my child it's like I I come to La for
like maybe like a week and I'll go home
like
you know I just you know try to make
time to make some extra money on the
side and then you know
so when you're making money are you
actually making money or are you making
it for your your dude
no I'm actually making money I got I got
a lot of responsibilities I mean
it's not like
he don't do for me you know or if I if I
need something that's like no I can't
get it for you right now if I need
something I get it immediately you know
so it's not like
I'm really like you know so he was
making you work and keeping all your
money nah I don't have to work if I
don't want to yeah 100 I can go home at
any given time with no problems no
arguing no issues I'm able to leave
whenever I feel like yeah
I'm able to be like hey can I get a can
I get 500 to go home with you know just
to spend it on this that and this you
know just tell them you know what you're
going to do with the money because you
know people want to know what are you
finna go home and do with this money are
you gonna go buy weed are you gonna go
get your hair and knows don't do nothing
for your baby what are you gonna go do
with this money you know so you know as
long as you let them know or tell them
what you're gonna go do with this money
then they have no problem giving it to
you
but most of these hoes like to go get
high with the money and do [ __ ] so
I don't know
everybody's situation is kind of like
different but what's the secret to doing
this kind of work not every girl can do
it yes the [ __ ] they can
any girl can do this yeah 100 look I
just had this white girl pull up on me
out of nowhere in her car right
she was just talking to me she's like I
never did this before you know
so I I was like okay she liked me so
much and she wanted to be around me so
I'm like you know you just can't be with
me she says she never wanted to do it
she didn't like
sorry to say she got sex trafficked
before you know so she was kind of
scared of doing this type of stuff you
know because she was forcing to it let
me tell you she did it don't ever say
she can't she she did it and then she
left me and I sent her right back out
there and she claims to be so scared
anybody can do it
I just met another female so she just
started doing this two days ago she
never did it in her life white girl just
started I'm like that's crazy as [ __ ]
right
anybody can do it Wednesday girl does it
for the very first time do you get over
that
no once a girl do it for the very first
time and they're in Need for money
they're going to keep doing it
yeah 100 because most girls that do this
are most likely in Need for money 100
so once they see somebody giving them
100 or 120 of course they're gonna keep
doing it because it's like free money
you know it's not all the time you gotta
[ __ ] some people just want to be like
talk to an event somebody to vent to
sometimes you know or I got a lot of
people that like foot fetishes I like to
suck my toes and jack off like most of
the time some hoes just they don't have
to [ __ ] you know
but anybody can do this yeah but do you
remember your first time
my first time
my first time was when I
uh on uh Imperial Highway
I was the first player I ever played
and I was out there all night
and I mean all night I was out there all
night like
I was cold
I get irritated fast I do not like the
code so I get I was just frustrated like
but you know I was in that car so it
wasn't like you know I get warm and then
once I get back outside I'm freezing but
it was like going for me though but I
would just get irritated when I'm back
in the cold but it was going like
and then I was like
once I started that I'm like okay since
now I know how to make money and I'm
young you know and all I got to do is
watch out for the police should I just
start doing it I left I had a female
I had a female uh pimp
when I first started it was a female I
ended up leaving her and then she'll
start doing it on my own
you've had bad things happen to you out
there
honestly
keep it so hot with you only bad thing I
ever had happened to me was me jumping
out of a car a moving car and burning up
like my shoulder my knees my forehead
and my back that's the only bad thing
that ever happened to me somebody's
trying to kidnap me and I had to jump
out and it was like two in the morning
so it wasn't no cars around no nothing
like
and my body just burnt up I had to go to
the hospital
but that's the only bad thing that ever
happened to me
to say
it's a dangerous job hey 100 because I
don't heard a lot of different stories
in
sheesh this this is dangerous though 100
I don't almost got hit by people trying
to chase me down and run me over and all
that type of stuff but I don't know what
a trick I ain't never really been like
raped or at gunpoint or ride by anybody
I don't know it just never happened to
me did you carry self-defense yeah I
carry maze um I really only carry mace
because I don't know
I just don't like I feel like the
females that mostly get like get that
type of treatment is the feelings that
have [ __ ] up attitudes and that's
being weird you know
I feel like it'd be them ones that be
having a bad luck but everybody
different but I ain't never had nothing
happened God forbid but yeah
how does it affect you emotionally doing
this
I mean it gets frustrating sometimes
because
that's right I like fast money so it's
like when the money not fast enough for
me I get real frustrated like I want
some money like and it's not fast enough
for me it's it's too slow like I don't
want to have to wait on my money you
know so it gets kind of frustrating when
it comes to the tricks and you know
but nowadays all these females out here
are doing bareback and um
in a 40 and 60 date so now on fig
a lot of tricks is putting up talking
about 20 and 30 and smoke weed with them
so it makes me more mad because it's
like
it was never like this and the money
gets slower and slower every day
so do kind of get like frustrating
does your family know you're doing it
yeah what do they say I mean they can't
say nothing now I'm grown maybe when I
was younger they felt some type of way
my aunties and them still asked me to
this day why am I still doing this like
I can be living a whole different type
of way
but I just choose to get money on my own
do you believe in karma yeah
how does karma play out in your life
honestly I ain't had no Bad Karma
I don't do nothing bad to anybody I'm
the sweetest person until you get on the
bad side of me like I really haven't I
haven't had any Karma
you've been in love before
you're only 19. huh you're only 19. have
I been in love before yeah uh
I mean
like
what is love I mean not what is love but
it's like how how can you know somebody
really love you you know that's a great
question somebody can tell you they love
you but how would you really know what
if they shown or did for you to say oh
yeah I'm in love with you or I just you
know this one I tell him I love him
every day like I love you to them like
you for me but it's like what really is
love because at the end of the day
you know
show me you love me let me prove to me
you love me buy me a big house and then
I'll understand you love me buy me a
Bentley truck and I I understand that
you love me you know put me in a better
position I understand that you love me
but now I have never really been in love
I'm quick to leave anybody like
I don't I don't even play them type of
games I'm quick to leave you recognize
BS when you see it yeah 100 percent
it's important on the streets right
right 100 is it is important it is
important what's the best example you
ever you saw as a child of a loving
relationship between a man and woman
my grandpa my grandma
they argue so much but they love each
other so much like they've been together
for like
almost like 50 something years
but they argue so much but they love
each other like he buys her everything
make sure she doesn't want for nothing
she does the same you feel me it's not a
a eye in team I mean yes it is
but they teamwork you know
so
you know that's what love is they they
do it together basically
does this work build up your self-esteem
or is it knock it down it builds up my
self-esteem my self-esteem is already
built up right you're already confident
I'm I'm hella confident myself I know
I'm pretty I love looking at myself I
know 100 I love it I love myself I love
my braces I love my I love everything
about me I swear I love my ass I love
everything about me I don't know
what's the best thing that's happened to
you while working the streets
the best thing that
happened was for me to break one trick
for 1500
well on fig like just like in a couple
minutes like couple like you know
1500.
what was the worst thing that's happened
to you
it's bad
what do you and the other girls talk
about when you're on the street
honestly I don't I don't talk to the
most because you want me to tell you why
all they want to talk about is pimps
that they had [ __ ] in the back streets
they ain't talking about no money I do
not talk to them because every hole you
go up to they talk about situation with
their folks or how they just [ __ ] this
[ __ ] in the back streets and his [ __ ]
right here I don't even want to get into
that I I just want some money so I can
go
there's really no friends in this
lifestyle
do you have no friends
because at the end of the day we all
host and all you hoes go back and talk
to another hole and tell them my
business and then it didn't happen so
many times I didn't seen it like there
is no friends in this [ __ ] nobody's your
friend
but that money that you're making
end of the day when you die You're Dying
by yourself you don't got no friends all
you got is your family
and the ones that care about you that
supports you so
is this a lonely lifestyle for you
um no I think I'm about to get into this
uh this business where I start doing
nails I was been supposed to do it but I
just stopped like I just stopped I'm
supposed to be doing nails and then I'm
gonna start doing this right here
my uncle has a um thing called NSG
called never stopped grinding where he
has all these type of programs for these
kids and stuff and he wants me to come
be like
um one of the girls that go talk to
other females about this right here
basically about my lifestyle so that's
another thing I'm probably end up doing
too telling them the ups and downs of it
yeah they don't want to get in this type
of life would you not recommend this to
a young girl no I would not 100
I wouldn't because Anything could happen
there's so many girls that came up
missing
like anything happened to anybody and I
wouldn't want nobody's little sister
nobody's niece or anybody out here
especially if they haven't been already
doing it and they just started like out
100 not Ricky because it's more
dangerous now
it's way more and it's a lot of minors
so it's like
no are you addicted to that fast money
um
yeah
I am it's gonna be hard to put that down
I tried to put it down
but it got hard
but this isn't gonna be a lifestyle
forever for me though by time I get um
in my 20s to 21 I should like be done
with this like I should be where I want
to be
do you regret getting into it
no not really
you're such a crazy lifestyle it is
your intuition's got to be heightened by
dealing with all these Hustlers on the
street man
I deal with a lot of people like
crazy people weird people dope heads
yeah
smokers that's what most of the guys
that pick you up are are drunk or high
no some of them be just regular people
on on some I'll I'm just trying to get
something quick I'm going to work or I
just got off work
like I I didn't dated a couple of
smokers though that and I make them
really pay those smokers you know
because I know they got a little bit of
you know I know they got some cats I
make them pay about 200 to come in my
room and to just you stink ill ill ill
foreign
[Music]
you get asked to do stuff that you're
uncomfortable with
as to do something I'm uncomfortable
with I'm going to tell them no okay I'm
gonna tell them no that's not what we do
and
that's nasty because most tricks won't
bear back and kissing why would you want
to kiss me you don't know me you don't
know if I got any STDs you don't know
nothing about me and you will never know
if I got an STD until you you find out
right you will never know until you find
out and that's just dirty a lot of these
girls do it oh wait a lot
and I said it's just unsafe that's like
your life you're putting your life on
risk to for some petting money
I don't think it's worth that it's not
worth that
it's more important You Love or Money
money
makes me happy
I can buy anything if I'm broke I can't
even go buy 50 Cent soda because it's
not free you for me can't do nothing
without no money you can't even say oh
damn I want to give me some food
but what money do I have
even if I want to go shopping with money
money the only thing I can make the
world go around and make people happy
money
do you have any regrets
uh no
I don't regretting that not finishing
school oh yeah I regret not finishing
school but um
I'm in the process as a friend I go to
uh go to this uh school where they where
I take this test and I pass and if I
pass I can just go get my colleague I
can get my degree and go to college
so yeah I think that's what I'm on the
road to do now
fear
Dr what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
19 years
don't trust nobody
be yourself you know state to yourself
be by yourself don't
feed into people's [ __ ] you feel me just
stick to getting money what you know
best 100 that's all I can tell anybody
because
share
that's all I wanted some money I don't
care about having friends I don't care
about none of that all I care about is
money you feel me and being happy though
too I'm not gonna lie I do care about
being happy I don't want to be miserable
getting money you feel me I do want to
be happy too but it comes it comes all
all together
in life
all right Dior thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah be careful out
there yeah have a good day thank you